[Music]
time now for morning rounds I look at
the medical news of the week according
to the Food and Drug Administration
three out of four Americans take dietary
supplements on a regular basis but the
forty billion dollar industry is not
highly regulated FDA Commissioner Scott
Gottlieb recently announced plans to
make the most significant changes to
supplement regulation in a quarter
century here to discuss that and a whole
lot more is CBS News medical contributor
dr. David agus thanks for joining us I'm
excited to be here well David well Scott
Godley tweeted and in part earlier this
week or so that just sentence Scott
Gottlieb tweeted tweeted was not making
statements on our air learned that he
was concerned the changes in the
supplement market are outpacing the
evolution of our own policies where are
we now and what are what are we seeking
to do you know 25 years ago they started
to put supplements out on the market and
this is new legislation there were 4,000
today there 80,000 there is no
requirement for them to be reviewed or
for them to list what's actually in them
before they go on the market so there
are some ethical good companies out
there that actually practice good but
there are many that do the wrong thing
you know in a study recently in
California they found hundreds had real
drugs in them yeah which was um
astonishing in New York State they filed
a that Attorney General here file
because there were sawdust or just
ground-up plants and most of the
supplements brings me back to that I
Love Lucy episode the vitae yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so I know you made the
study that you're talking about the
California Health Department Department
of Health Study which looked at what's
in these things I mean you mentioned a
couple things but I mean what exactly
are they putting in there and why is it
there in these they took the real drug
and they put it in so they said well
this helps with potency and there was
real viagra in it you don't know you're
taking a medicine it can interact with
other medicine right now you know the
problem is is that you look at this
industry 40 50 billion dollars and none
of them have been proven none of them
have an effect on a disease I mean
dr. Gottlieb this week said we're taking
down these compounds that actually said
they're gonna help Alzheimer's help
dementia help cancer and he tweeted
pictures you know almost mocking it that
these companies are advertising and
taking advantage of people you know four
out of five elderly one in three
children take these we have to step up
and protect you talk about stepping up
and that's where we're going next 65
years ago today dr. Jonas Salk
administered the first mass injections
of the polio vaccine to a group of
elementary school students in Pittsburgh
before the vaccine polio caused more
than 15,000 cases of paralysis every
year no cases have originated in the
United States since 1979 and this is
where we get to the step up the story
behind the vaccine you were telling us
about it in the commercial break it's
fascinating it's heroic right I mean
it's absolutely heroic 400000 first
second and third graders were given the
vaccine 200,000 were given placebo and
this was done by volunteers hundreds of
thousands of volunteers no
pharmaceutical company no government the
nation stepped up and took this scourge
that was hitting all of us right and
basically eliminated it it is the most I
mean listen I get teary-eyed just
thinking about it
it is heroic you know leadership causes
normative behavior change we saw that
then we sorely need that in health and
medicine today dr. Gottlieb also
mentioned that he might step into the
whole debate when it comes to states on
on the IV actions of the laws in those
states when it comes to vaccines what's
your take mention to retweeted
[Laughter]
Commissioner Gottlieb said rightly so is
that we need to take on people who are
anti vaccine there are three states now
where you can only have a medical
exemption you can't have other
exemptions and we need to decide we're
seeing measles outbreaks in states I
mean measles these kids are not given
the future they should have because they
weren't vaccinated and they could harm
other kids and so it really is a
national issue that we have to step up
and use these vaccines that save lives
and prevent disease dr. David agus good
message to end on thank you very much